et c'est qui est là d'accord d'accord
comment tu vas te le dire en face à lui
me présente pas si si si bien sûr adrien
je te présente le pont non c'est pas
estelle la première non c'est pas la
belle solide ou pas du tout cl non
peut-être expliquer une teinture je vais
l'emmener et on s'en branle on dit un
prénom qui font mieux
sandrine on a besoin de plus de temps
fait peu parler
j 24 mai les seconds couteaux place mais
les au plus tard mais c'est beaucoup
trop long
s200 on est sûr de ça parce que des fois
on croit que ça commence pareil sinon
c'est sûr y'a un ace dedans j'ai un
souvenir
concentré
mieux
omer dans le tempo c'est qu'ils savent
elles étaient avec moi la soirée c'est
qui est bon [ __ ] il nous faut à nous
on réfléchit baird réfléchi je viens
donc je scène c'est le monde notre
concierge adhère
mais si l'uci c'est lui le site ici
c'est ma soeur moi c'est sandrine où
j'avais novembre une valeur 71,04 fois
je te dis pour thème un point bas je
l'avais déjà en fête
mathias je m'appelle mathias